frey martiniquais de nous faire
guadeloupe et de nous faire ici genou
frais qui sont partis parce que leurs
racines
c'est un africain en afrique c'est pour
ça on a érigé à ouidah un port une porte
du non retour et d'un autre discussion
en créer ici une porte du retour ou que
les martiniquais se retrouvent robinet
chez eux et que les béninois c'est au
tour en martinique également chez les
deux villes de rigueur et de france les
autres au laboureur sombre traverse
gagnant gagnant exactement
le partenariat commencer par les deux
villes et c'est heureux que ça
s'étendent en même temps sur l'espace
sud de la martinique
et ça doit s'étendre également à
l'espace central de la martinie à
l'espace du nord vous savez que le roi
bien c'est l'ancien voire d'y dormir a
fait une douzaine d'années avant d'être
importés en algérie allait mourir
l'algérie sur le plan historique
nous avons une mini fort avec la
martinique dans le partenariat duel
gains
nous avons à recevoir prendre des
martiniquais les matignon afin de
recevoir de leurs frais africain tube in
dans un premier temps le partenariat
cible d'abord les jeunes
oui sa cible surtout les jeunes parce
que l'avenir c'est les jeunes l'avenir
du monde entier ces régions et au
binaire comme ici la jeunesse représente
le fer de lance est le seul
développement le développement futur
doit pouvoir se fonder sur le jules vous
ça que je suis est de constater qu'il y
à déjà des jeunes qui vont partir ils
ont reçu les deux dernières années de
fortes délégations du martiniquais
robinet et le cumin nour par une
vingtaine des martiniquais début août il
ya une quarantaine de martiniquais qui
vont au bénin donc mais le développement
concret du partenariat les liant pour
les installer et ouidah on est heureux
de constater grâce à l'espace sud
ça va commencer par les jeunes qui vont
rencontrer les jeunes béninois et
ensemble ils vont commencer à mettre un
en oeuvre de manière concrète cette
relation entre les deux parties un peu
les deux peuples